hey what's up my name is samuel leeds i
am a property investor
and in this video i want to answer your
property investment
questions so if you have any questions
at all what's holding you back what do
you need to know what those little
annoying
niggly questions that you can't seem to
find the answer to when you just do
normal google searches
whether it be around lease options rent
to rent
deal packaging business mortgages please
comment below and i will do my very best
to answer
your questions your struggles and the
themes and topics that you want to hear
about so
comment below that would be great also
don't forget to subscribe
turn the notification bell on and also
hit the like button as well that would
really help me out so go ahead and smash
like
and let's see what people are asking to
hear about
so last q and a sunday video that i did
i had
a guy called man like ik
who said question what's the process
of getting a better credit score and
everything you need
for an 18 year old so
man like ik man like ik
i'm trying to work out what that means
but anyway um credit score firstly
credit score is really important if
you're going to be a property investor
it really helps if you have a good
credit score
why because if you've got a good credit
score it makes it easier to borrow money
to then invest that money otherwise
you're gonna have to use either your own
money
which is really bad because that means
you have to work really hard to use your
own money
bad plan or you're gonna have to borrow
someone else's money or use someone
else's credit score
but it helps if your credit score is
good so great question what can you do
to make it good well the very first
thing i'll say is
know what your credit score is how do
you do that
there's websites such as um noddle
and um experian
and different websites but if you just
google check my credit score there's
websites i think they're free or pretty
much free maybe a really small
subscription where you can find out
what your credit score is so the
mortgage lenders
when they lend to you they're going to
look at what your credit score is find
out what your score is
and then when you know what it is if
it's good bad average
fair bit poor work to get it in the
excellent category
um some little things that you can do
are
make sure that you're registered to the
electoral roll
if you're not registered on the
electoral roll to vote it will
negatively affect your credit score
make sure that you've got no little
outstanding unpaid
bills for instance if you've got if
you've paid your mobile phone bill late
or you've got an outstanding debt and
you've not paid it it could be flagging
up on your credit score
it should show you when you couldn't
score if it's bad
why it's bad fix it and fix it quickly
be patient
and that's probably what i would say but
definitely keep working on that credit
score guys
all right bethany haley well i currently
work minimum wage and a fair amount of
my wages goes to rent and food
i have a student debt and don't have
enough income for a deposit or a
mortgage
the bank won't lend to me how can i
afford to buy a property
great question bethany there's many
things you can do
for a start you could buy a property on
a lease option
agreement that means buy a property now
but agree to pay for it
later as in in five seven years
that gives you the time to save up
your deposit and to get your mortgage
ability's credit score
in a good place so that at the end of
the five years or seven years
you buy the house for a price that you
agree today
now the awesome thing is about that not
only does it give you time to save up
and does it give you time to get your
credit score sorted you can get a
mortgage
but also over time houses tend to go up
so after five or seven years you've got
a bargain and on top of that how are you
going to save up your deposit
where's that money going to come from
you're a minimum wage well you can use
the rent from the property
to save the money deposit it sounds a
little bit too good to be true doesn't
it
it really isn't it's just called a lease
option agreement i've done
many of these and served many of my
students so i probably suggest
looking at that hope that helps okay
hashim
says one of my concerns
is if i had a property which no tenants
are interested in and it cannot be
rented out
what would you do um great question
hashim so what happens
if you get a house maybe you buy it now
and pay for it later
but then you can't rent it out that
would be really terrible well the answer
is
firstly and you might want to remember
this is every
house will rent out at the right price
your job when taking on the house is to
figure out what the right price
is we are in a small island
and there's a shortage of houses there's
a shortage of homes
and there's an overpopulation of people
so if you've got a house it will rent
out as long as it's
habitable but it's not like really run
down or anything it will
rent out no matter where it is it's just
a case of working out what the right
price is by speaking to
estate agents or letting agents in the
area assessing the right price
the reason most people have no tenants
in their house or they have an empty
property
is because the letting agent will say oh
you'll easily rent this out for 600
pounds a month
but actually the letting agency is being
a little bit optimistic
so you put it on for 600 but there's
others on the market for 550
and your house is sitting there empty
but if you just
if you just put it at the right price it
should rent out right
so speak to letting agents be
conservative
reduce the rent slightly if you have to
um
and and make sure you do proper due
diligence in an area but remember
anything will rent out at the right
price hope that helps okay
huss nain shah says
i've been watching your q a sundays
since you first came out with it wow
that's impressive because i've been
doing this for years
but i've never asked a question you've
never asked a question and you've been
watching for years
listen guys if you watch my q a sundays
every week and you've never asked a
question
today is the day to break that pattern
and ask your questions all right let's
see what hussein has to say
when you're buying a property that is
strictly a cash purchase
and it's not mortgageable is it possible
to do an option agreement with the
vendor
to do the bare minimum to just make it
mortgageable say no kitchen or bathroom
and just put a used one in
and then sell it at a much higher price
and then keep the difference so that
when we put it back on the market
there's still enough profit for someone
else to come in
and do it up to an excellent standard
for example
a property selling for 150 000 pounds
cash purchase
and value 230. so we come and do a
little bit of work and put it on the
market for 175
and now it's mortgageable this way we
put in a little bit of money just to
make it mortgageable and then sell it
onto an investor which will do the full
refurb
um yeah that is possible that is very
possible in fact that's something that
um myself and my wife have done
uh many times we've bought a property
that's completely run down and instead
of doing it all up to a really high
standard
we've just fixed the kitchen and
bathroom and then sold it
so it is possible you can also do with
an option agreement
as well so yeah you can do that my
friend
okay last question okay so get
commenting folks let's see your
questions
ajaz b says right 75k available to spend
equity was released from my hand do i go
down the hmo route or buy two or three
properties on the buy to let mortgages
and pull it all down on a derelict or
put it all down on a dairy property
also in my city of nottingham not many
properties available in my price bracket
would you recommend a different location
with a high rental yield but the
properties are around 50 to 70k
thanks mate ajaz um great question thank
you and congratulations on pulling out
some equity on one of your homes or your
home you've got 75k
it depends on what you want to achieve
are you looking for cash flow
or are you looking for capital
appreciation are you looking to get some
quick fast pounds or are you looking to
build wealth and have slow pound and
build your net worth over time
if i had 75k and i lived in nottingham i
would probably be tempted
to buy a property on an auction
around nottingham a single house for
about 75k
buy it cash run down then get a
development financial bridging loan to
do it up
and then refinance it and try and pull
out all or most of my money
so i can get my money back and then i
would do it again
once i've done that once or twice and i
had a bit of experience
i would then show investors what i'm
doing and i would then
lend joint venture on a bigger deal
maybe a hmo in nottingham
and start growing and joint venturing my
way to becoming a property
millionaire i hope that helps
hey thank you for watching the video i
appreciate every single person
that tunes in that asks questions that
likes the video that comments support
subscribes
so thank you so much i look forward to
the next video where i'll be answering
your questions to this video don't
forget to drop your question in
subscribe and i'll see you soon thank
you peace out